CBS News confirms Jared Kushner the
president's son-in-law and senior
advisor has given materials to Special
Counsel Robert Muller the documents are
related to his role in the firing of FBI
director James Comey and there are new
questions about attorney general Jeff
Sessions knowledge of Russian contacts
with Trump campaign associates Paula
Reid is at the Justice Department
tracking the Russian investigation Paula
good morning good morning sources close
to the process say that the documents
that Kushner has handed over our email
messages from his private account and
that there were no relevant documents
linked to his White House email account
now former Trump campaign chairman Paul
Manafort returned to federal court
Thursday with his GPS ankle bracelet
intact after addressing the press on
Monday his attorneys could get slapped
with a gag order to shield potential
jurors judge Amy Berman Jackson said
yesterday this is a criminal trial not a
public relations campaign we've also
learned that former foreign policy
adviser to the Trump campaign George
papadopolis who reached a secret plea
deal pitched his Russia connections
during a March 31st 2016 meeting
sessions attended the meeting along with
then candidate Trump a source familiar
with the meeting told CBS News sessions
immediately rejected the plan by
Papadopoulos sessions has testified that
he does not recall any meetings between
Russian officials and other tram
campaign associates no attorney general
sessions has not been called to testify
before the grand jury Muller could be
more interested in him as a focus of the
collusion investigation and not just a
mere witness Gail
all right Paula thank you very much